we know each other a long time
we do uh you i know you as one of the
finest
impressionists you do you do great
impressions besides that i'm delighted
that you have a show because
you're fresh you're funny you're great
and i want you to know something
from my heart i never liked you
now i heard she gave you an ipad did did
you think that was a woman's product
would you even know what it was
you know that's the truth i know nothing
about if the television goes
with the blinking at midnight i don't
know i don't know the first thing about
it
but now i got it on television stays on
after midnight
how about how about how about shut up
but do you do a little exercise yeah i
ride a bike about recumbent bike
i should date do you watch with him let
me finish hi dave
i know it's your show but i have a
little curtis i'm sorry a little respect
i'm much older than you i understand and
by the way the snow is getting a little
brighter up there all right thank you
but i went to the american academy of
dramatic arts which they keep it quiet
you know
robert redford's jason robots were you
on scholarship daughter no no no i just
walked in and started acting ah you
don't get a scholarship you pay you got
to audition
don't be a dumbbell i hate it
read the paper know the questions i mean
what does it stump the stars no no i was
just
oh i used to go down in the locker room
you know right the dodgers in the old
day tommy would say done
oh the best one right he said go out to
the mound and take the picture out
on appreciation it's true and i i put on
the uniform i said
tommy you'll get fine don't worry just
go out there i walk out to the mountain
in the game in the middle of the game no
in detroit
how did you get this show i don't know
[ __ ]
telling a story where do you think it
was yeah
just put out just sit there and hope to
god you got the job
and uh she and i were down there and uh
we were working at the uh
grand casino in outside of memphis
outside how far outside what the hell
are you from the travel agency
i don't remember casino gamble who wants
to remember nobody what are you what are
you my guardian i'm not going to tell
you where i go
cheetah 40 million jews i got to meet a
truant officer here
uh so uh would you watch your diet yeah
sure
i got a steak once in a while and you
know they always say isn't that right
all of that you don't have to be that
attentive you don't have to be like
don't give me that he gives me that crap
like he's interested
[Applause]
you know jimmy you don't have to you
come out when they say give me about
jimmy blah blah blah it's a little much
what happens right every guest
show the crime again it's a nice thing
steve canadian no there is
that a guy comes out with a nervous
breakdown
and in fact uh in fact he gave me uh one
of those uh you know he's got a
lightning bolt is the lightning bolt
yeah what about
is this a playback he's got a lightning
what does
everything i say i get the feeling i got
a problem
can you hear him the guy here in the
front
snap out of it huh an old guy right the
front door
what a night
there you go ah it's lovely to see you
over here buddy over here right
here i mean you staring at them for no
they do it's so sweet to stand up i
guess the underwear stuck
that's so sweet of you really when you
get older you know when you get that
kind of reception you
you want to walk away and say why am i
with him yeah
you good
two and a half years two and a half
years looking for your uncle
navy world war ii big one big one
cebu tacloban lingarian gulf mindanao i
was there
all i'll be with you in a minute
all trees all jungle now big cities
wonderful
we went up to manila and macarthur is
still sitting am i dead
god bless you great country i'm not
going back there no no
we went uh oh many years ago my wife and
i
when the trump plaza just went up and we
said we're going to see the apartments
this is your wife barbara i'm talking to
that
no it's a hooker from detroit
what the hell's the matter with you no
i'm sorry tonight you're a nervous wreck
you're going to brooklyn like it's
exciting christ
build a bridge on your ass and go home
early
no i uh we had a wonderful cruise we
went to vietnam i think i told you about
it went to china who takes a cruise to
vietnam oh
no our life is gonna be this sitting
here all day long my next guest you
don't do anything for crying out loud
you sit in a house with your wife maeve
is going my next guest and she says
you're home more on your home forget
about it
we go on trips you going kids we go to
china what's those guys
[Music]
tommy says take the picture out take the
picture what do you keep doing i don't
know
when you make love to your lady go did
we do it yes we did did we do it
oh you know what i want to ask you about
when i come back about when you panicked
new heart was on here
no no he said you panicked you were
stricken
with fear i was there we'll tell the
honest about it when we come back see
this is a teaser to get them to stay is
that what it is
because really you're dull
don among many other things you have
always to me represented las vegas in
its heyday
when there was genuine excitement i ask
you something yeah sure are you holding
something
[Laughter]
anyway what was your name again who
cares what her name is
kevin bacon's kevin bacon's wife that's
right well you're jewish that's kevin
bacon what does that got to do with why
do you think your name is
but i figured it's bacon and that's the
separate what is this a nazi movie
[Applause]
[Music]
what's jewish got to do heaven tonight
he's black did i make a big thing out of
it
[Music]
good seeing you don do you like the
california life
of course my hunting dogs we have a big
estate the wife keeps running on the
ground saying
we're rich we're rich it's it's it's a
wonderful life it was better than miami
in two rooms with my mother raised her
soul
lifting up the curtain and saying do you
have a girl in there
no it's a great life you got to come out
here larry as soon as you can chip in
and get a jacket
you know i don't know where i'm looking
i'm talking to a blank screen you're
over there i don't know where i'm
talking to
i feel like i'm char ray charles without
my organ
what do you think of our studios in los
angeles i think they're cheap and they
should be painted
bad area really well i walked into the
office one big drape and 100 people
sitting at a desk going
they're all are days larry do yourself a
favor walk away from this you don't need
it
nobody gets cnn in california a little
german guy and the seller is still
trying to read hitler he's going i think
i got larry king it's a little
little seller don you're getting am i
right are you getting gray
yes larry i'm getting older doing shows
like this
what